chers collègues le débat du jour n'est
que le prémi de l'étude du 29e texte
depuis 1980 sur ce sujet la France ne
peut pas accueillir tout le monde si
elle veut accueillir bien voilà ce que
déclarait le président 2019 pourtant
rien dans les derniers budgets présentés
ou des dernières politiques annoncées
nées le reflet de cette doctrine si
mieux accueillir ses procédés dans le
budget 2023 une baisse des crédits
octroyés pour la location des demandeurs
d'asile de plus d'un tiers la discussion
risque d'être compliquée dans le
décalage entre les actes et la parole
est grande je crois au vrai en même
temps sur la politique migratoire aussi
disait-il toujours dans ce même
entretien
ce que nous voyons ne me semble être que
la jambe droite de cette politique
migratoire peut-être parce que c'est
celle qui porte réellement ses
convictions comment sinon justifier le
prise ultra présent de la spéc sécurité
comment comprendre qu'un sujet de
société importante depuis cette
considéré comme réellement prise en
charge qu'au travers d'une vision
sécuritaire peut-être aurions-nous aimé
voir et nous pencher sur la création
d'un véritable ministère dédié à la
politique de l'immigration de l'accueil
et de l'intégration
pourquoi ne pas regarder ce débats sous
l'aspect humanitaire de fraternité de
solidarité et même de réalisme ou de
pragmatisme économique sociale et
climatique non je le redis les questions
d'immigration ne peuvent pas se limiter
ni même s’aborder prioritairement via
leur HP sécurité le débat d'aujourd'hui
devrait je l'espère permettre de
recentrer l'immigration un phénomène
normal historique récurrent qui a
participé et participera à la
construction de notre pays un phénomène
démographique complexe tributaire des
guerres des famines conséquences mettant
du changement climatique un phénomène
qui conduira encore plus de mouvements
dans les années à venir entre les
continents et au sein même de l'Europe
en 2017
le candidat Prométhée nous examinerons
les demandes d'asile en moins de 6 mois
recours compris c'est nécessaire pour
accueillir dignement les réfugiés qui
ont droit à la protection de la France
pourtant pour les juridictions
administratives et pour la CNDA les
Costa sont les mêmes une embolisation
totale d'un système mal calibré de
l'accès au préf et à l'OFI pour
l'obtention le cercle nouvellement de
titre de séjour en passant par l'accès
au travail jusqu'à une prise en charge
médicale effective les parcours des
migrants sont trop souvent semés
d'embûches tout le contraire de
profiteur du système maintenant des
milliers de personnes dans la précarité